on l'a surnommé le camp de la honte un
parc municipal à la grande synthe près
de dunkerque où s'entassent près de 2000
réfugiés ils vivent ici les pieds dans
l'eau dans la boue luttant comme ils
peuvent
contre l'humidité et le froid hivernal
compresse que tous ici
as cannes d'art car annie son épouse et
son jeune fils de neuf mois viennent du
kurdistan irakien
ils ont fui la guerre les exactions du
coup par melita islamique et rêve de
s'installer en grande-bretagne mais les
contrôles renforcés aux frontières ont
rendu la destination inaccessible alors
ils sont coincés en france depuis un
mois et demi la viauderie crible la vie
n'est pas bonne ici dit il
c'est très mauvaise et très froid les
comptes le camp de la grande synthe est
tenu à bout de bras depuis des mois par
une poignée d'organismes humanitaires
comme médecins sans frontières beaucoup
de bénévoles aussi qui distribue
vêtements couvertures et nourriture
des petits gestes qui font toute la
différence pour ceux qui n'ont plus rien
bart wouters par exemple quitte la
hollande chaque semaine pour venir ici
simplement pour offrir des crêpes
chaudes aux réfugiés
je veux juste leur rendre la vie plus
agréable style leur donner le sourire
angélique muller de médecins sans
frontières est habitué à être déployé
dans tous les coins chauds du globe
comme le sud soudan où le congo mais
elle se désole aujourd'hui de devoir
intervenir chez elle en france elle
déplore l'inaction de son gouvernement
c'est plus qu'étonnant moi je vous dis
c'est révoltant aussi que l'état ne
veuille pas prendre ses responsabilités
ces gens ne veulent pas être là la base
un faux quand même qu'on se le dise un
if lui des persécutions ils fuient les
guerres ils fuient ces des survivants
ils sont pas par goût par gaieté de
coeur sur un camp et surtout pas sur un
camp comme ça
une chose est claire le coût actuel
n'est pas aux normes internationales
le haut commissariat de l'onu pour les
réfugiés préconise que chaque famille
ait accès à ses propres toilettes ou en
tout cas qu'il y ait un maximum de 20
personnes par latrines ici c'est trois
fois plus d'ailleurs dans lequel il ya
déjà 2 devant l'inaction de l'état et
voyant les conditions dans le camp se
détériorer le maire de la ville de la
grande scène a entrepris de faire
construire lui-même un nouveau camp
rouge aux normes internationales c'est
pas normal c'est pas une compétence
d'une ville mais comme il se passe rien
ben voila je n'accepterai pas que
quelqu'un meure sur le territoire de ma
commune parce qu'on le laisse crever
dans le froid et ou de faim donc ça
c'est que c'est clair moi ça défile dans
mes tripes je ne peux pas faire
autrement
le nouveau camp qui permettra aux
réfugiés d'être au sec dans des tentes
chauffées devrait ouvrir au début du
mois de mars
d'ici là les milliers d'habitants du
camp de la honte devront prendre leur
mal en patience et continuer de vivre
dans le froid les pieds dans la boue
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
à la grande synthe dans le nord de la
france